Robert Pattinson the wells newest Bruce
Wayne recently revealed that he's in the
process of buffing up for the Batman but
what exactly does that training regimen
entail here's how the English actor is
getting ready for his next a big role
they say their abs are made in the
kitchen but revealed in the gym and
Pattinson implemented a pretty
particular method of eating to build a
superhero physique in his own words
Pattinson is an extremist when it comes
to his eating choices and that's all go
on a months-long junk food bender before
it comes time for him to drop weight
Pattinson apparently took this approach
for the Batman during an interview with
BuzzFeed in October 2019 he claimed I'll
eat nothing but pizzas for months so by
the time we have to diet my body is like
thank God please only healthy stuff from
now he also mentioned that he began a
process of bulking up for the Batman for
those unaware bulking is a common
dietary practice and can be done by
everyone from professional athletes to
actors prepping for a role to an
everyday person wanting to literally
bulk up their body either in preparation
for a muscle to finding weights curse or
simply to keep extra pounds on their
frame in general there's no one right
way to bulk though two of the most
popular and well-known methods are clean
bulking and dirty bulking those who
practice a clean bulk gain mass by
eating a caloric surplus taking in more
calories than their basal metabolic rate
or BMR thus the total amount of energy
one expense simply by being a life a
clean bulk involves choosing healthier
foods to chow down on think oatmeal and
brown rice almond and peanut butter
proteins like salmon chicken and lean
beef and healthy fats like avocados
olive oil and full fat coconut milk
those who dirty bulk on the other hand
smashing calories from all kinds of
sources the denser the better and from
its interviews that sounds like the
route Pattinson took
there's a hot dog you shall not
makes you fall in love while his best
friends at one point may have been Papa
John in Little Caesar Pass incentives
now adopted a cleaner diet and us cuss
out more than just the cops in a feature
for the health and fitness magazine
healthy for men it's noted that
Pattinson cut down on alcohol and
reduces intake of processed meats in
addition to resisting the temptation of
fried foods all in the effort to get his
body into superhero shape giving a beer
and saying so long to something
deep-fried may be difficult for us
everyday people but for Pattinson and
other superhero actors it's all part of
the job and from the way he described
his pizza heavy phase his body probably
thanked him switching to a healthier
eating plan for actors looking to change
their bodies for a film a fitness
routine goes hand-in-hand with their
diet of choice sometimes that involves
very little working outs and a whole lot
of pies Christian Bale's combo of choice
when he was skating wait to play former
Vice President Dick Cheney in Vice other
times it requires pushing a 5,000 pound
Jeep across a parking lot and only
eating junk food as a reward for working
else which is what brie Larson did while
prepping for Captain Marvel pointers
exercise or lack thereof it's just as
important as diet when it comes to
transforming your body but in sons a
smart guy so he knows this thankfully
his new perspective on exercise made his
Batman movie prep a lot easier while
speaking to interviewer Margaret's
gardener during the lights House press
circuit in the fall of 2019 Pattinson
revealed that he was weirdly looking
forward to getting in shape for the
Batman which is all thanks to his new
feelings about exercise he shared with a
laugh I didn't like exercise when I was
younger now as I've kind of gotten older
I'm suddenly getting aware of aging it's
like I need to put some effort in
otherwise I'm gonna need a hip
replacement the actor followed up on
that fourth in a separate interview with
BuzzFeed saying I used to hate working
out in my 30s I find it very meditative
it's weird when you feel like someone's
not forcing it on you and you're doing
it for yourself it's a very different
experience I'm really looking forward to
it when the time came to put thoughts
into action I'm agin working out for the
Batman Pattinson kept his exercise
routine varied according to healthy for
men the actor would perform a
five-minute cardio workout
followed by a strength training circuit
consisting of crunches side bends and
the core work but instead also picked up
a habit of regularly running three to
six miles three to four times per week
the actor also took up boxing and have
been spotted doing what healthy for men
called military-style sandbag routines
likely to add excitement into his
exercise regime and to increase strength
and agility we understand the gym stuff
but incentive time to unwind or still
getting outside and moving about taking
long walks to rest the body and soothe
the mind
sounds like Pattinson will be one
balance dude in interviews Pattinson has
opened up about what it's been like to
take on the role of Batman for the actor
who's received most acclaimed for his
turns in drama that didn't require
physical transformations
he knows looking like Bruce Wayne is
just as important as acting like him he
admitted that the lockdowns are world
governments imposed in the face of the
corona virus pandemic have impacted his
progress births he's determined to keep
going and do his absolute best as a new
Batman because ultimately this has been
an exciting learning experience for
Pattinson heat old healthy for men in
every project I've ever taken on I've
come into it wanting to learn and to
achieve new things that's usually in the
embodiment of a character and so on who
has a different personality to me but
taking on a full physical transformation
as well feels even more exciting a few
years ago I would have run a mile from
anything with a physical edge button
Singh continued sharing that he does
wonder whether he can live up to
expectations in terms of both
physicality and his actual performance
but he understands us normal plus he
knows darkness isn't entirely on him to
look unbelievably buff Pattinson
apparently plans to continue getting
ripped without damaging his body and
then let moviemaking Magica take care of
the rest you look at the true warriors
of the superhero genre Hemsworth the
rock Downey jr. Evans and wonder if
you're putting yourself in the wrong
place and yes having spoken to a few I
know everyone is nervous when the
opportunity comes about it's all about
pushing boundaries and building up to a
point where you know you can do justice
to the physicality required and pass
that so much of it is letting the
special effects and on-screen exchanges
produce surreal magic overall it's just
very exciting
fans can see the fruits of Robert
Pattinson labor when the Batman hits
theaters on October 1st
2021 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper
about your favorite movies and TV shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the Bell so you don't
miss a single one